bonjour nicolas mirkovic merci de
répondre à nos questions plus de trente
mille personnes ont déjà quitté le don
de base 10 trains de dix wagons devrait
arriver dans la journée en russie et ce
matin le chef de la république
autoproclamée du donetsk 1 située à
celui de longues enquêtes programme ce
matin la mobilisation générale est ce
que ce sont les signes de l'imminence
d'un conflit
ça démontre en tout cas la crainte le
conflit du faut pas oublier que ça fait
depuis le 2014 kim a cessé il ya eu des
moments de des guerres de mouvement est
une guerre de positions mais la guerre
n'est pas quelque chose de nouveau dans
le donbass il faut le rappeler il ya des
tirs tous les jours depuis 2014 là on
arrive à un moment extrêmement grave
extrêmement critique personnellement
j'avais encore jamais vu ça même le
début de la guerre ou autant de lier une
à tête décision de mobiliser a donc mais
les réservistes ça ça paraît tout à fait
normal mais qui sait décision
d'évacuation la population on peut
craindre le pire est en tout cas ça
montre que les responsables de ces deux
de la république autoproclamée créer des
e pour le pire ils craignent ils disent
clairement qu'ils ont peur de l'invasion
luc reinette cette invasion
qu'ils ont repoussée depuis le 2014 ils
craignent que ce soit imminente
n'oublions pas qu'ils aient acquis il ya
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
soldats ukrainiens qui sont passés sur
la frontière depuis novembre dernier et
elle cette décision n'a été prise
justement je pense pour protéger les
civils pas à cause de cette à cause de
ses craintes de l'invasion de l'armée
ukrainienne
l'ukraine et les mines à lui république
autoproclamée du donbass s'accusent
mutuellement de nouvelles attaques selon
l'osce il y a eu donc une recrudescence
de combats dans la région ces dernières
heures ce qui veut dire clairement que
le cessez le feu n'est pas respecté or
pourtant le cessez le feu c'est l'un des
points phares un désaccord de minsk
alors qui croire il ya une guerre de
communication
il ya clairement c'est une guerre de
publication d'ici se bat des deux côtés
c'est la réalité regardez les rapports
de l'oas et où vous même le regarder la
formation et du côté ils seraient pas
des deux côtés le sujet est que l'état
d'ukraine l'état de droit dit quel jeu
là et or daumas elles tirent sur des des
miliciens ddd de la république qui a eu
riposte alors qui a commencé il ya
toujours le peuple l'a fait la poule
parce que certains spéculent dans les
accords
minsk 2 ils doivent cesser je doive
trouver les moyens de px et l'ukraine au
moment de l'offre à kiev ne montre pas
du tout c'est le monte en ce moment en
amassant toutes ses troupes sur la
frontière en continuant à tirer sur ces
deux sur ces deux républiques donc du
coup je pense que un message clair et
important et emmanuel macron l'avait
demandé à ben la lumière la semaine
dernière quand il avait dit mettez en
place de ces le feu cessez le feu si
l'ukraine pour montrer qu'elle est à
l'état de droit edd vrai cessez le feu
je peux vous garantir que si dit
qu'elles cessent le feu et bien il y
aura plus de
mener de le dire un emmanuel macouin
entre rencontré volodine merzhin ce
qu'il n'ya pas très longtemps et puis la
rencontre également vladimir poutine
justement le président français
s'entretiendra aujourd'hui avec son
homologue ukrainien et demain avec le
président russe sachant qu'il ya aussi
la conférence annuelle de la sécurité à
munich ce week-end nous serons là
vice-présidente américaine avec un mal à
aris qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre de
cette nouvelle journée de tractations
diplomatiques d'après vous
oui parce que c'est beaucoup de choses
en coulisses ça c'est sûr et certain
comme depuis ces dernières semaines j'ai
pas se réduire ces derniers mois c'est
ça sa petite là le geste d république et
un geste fort je pense que c'est un
geste qui a vite à une intervention en
tout cas une à une réaction rapide de
délits gérant pour trouver la paix
idéalement parce qu'on ne sait pas ce
qui peut arriver peut-être prochaines
heures et bien ça va être escalade delà
de la guerre de position qui va se
transformer en guerre de guerre de
mouvement je pense que dans cette
situation on va boire autant d'acteurs
qui officiellement veulent la paix dans
la région c'est quand même quelque chose
d'assez incroyable qui n'arrivent pas à
se mettre d'accord au moins pour qu'il y
ait un cessez le feu au moins pour que
ces civils puis sont retournés chez eux
le plus des images terribles hier des
images au 21e siècle en ordre
d'orphelins qui ont déjà une vie assez
compliqué comme ça évacués de leur
orphelinat d oublier de prendre des
dégâts dans des conditions rapides
d'urgence pour partir en russie on peut
mettre fin ça quel état européen peut
permettre ça sur ce qu'est le président
européen peut tolérer ça sur l'autel sur
le territoire européen il faut à tout
prix dire à l'armée ukrainienne ccd
l'épaule les tirs de ne pas parler
également avec les républiques et je
pense que c'est important que qu'il
parle avec les républiques pour qu'ils
se mettent autour de la table et qu'ils
discutent dans un cadre qui existent
déjà que le cas des accords de ya un
accord entre celle entre les républiques
et l'ukraine il faut qu'il soit une mise
en place l'album moment avec toutes les
personnes qui sont au conseil de
sécurité de munich de dire maintenant on
arrête on met en place des accords de
minsk 2 et un dialogue ouvert la paix
c'est indispensable un dialogue donc une
voie diplomatique qui est toujours
ouverte un seul homme à joe biden et et
vous l'a dit mir poutine cette crise est
ce qu elle peut donc se régler encore
par des négociations et si oui quel
consensus chaque partie peut-elle
prendre
elle peut se régler par le la diplomatie
mais il va falloir faire vite parce que
je le rappelle cette guerre de culture
depuis 2014 on rentre dans la de la 6eme
le dans la dans le lui dis qu'on peut
également parce qu'il ya un état
d'urgence qui est instaurée également
dans la région de rostov 1 villes russes
vers laquelle sont évacués justement les
six villes
de l'ouest de l'ukraine c'est justement
du coup il faut que cette situation
diplomatique se règle rapidement parce
qu'au bout du monde dans la huitième
année de guerre au bout d'un moment
malheureusement le disait claude pivi
cela la guerre c'est la politique par
d'autres moyens il n'y aura pas d'autre
solution que la règle est définitivement
par la guerre ça fait huit ans quand
même des chances à la diplomatie et
qu'on n'y arrive pas et je pense que les
habitants des républiques ont vraiment
n'en peuvent plus et donc du coup il
peut y avoir des situations qui se
termine en guerre et les potées sait pas
de quel côté ça peut partir mais au bout
d'un moment si les personnes arrivent
pas se parler mais il va falloir fier
qu'il soit plus fort que l'autre et qui
est qu'il ya eu malheureusement c'est
comme ça c'est terrible à dire mais la
voie diplomatique pour l'instant
n'avance pas on espère au moins qui on
pourra obtenir un cessez-le-feu dans
l'est dans les prochains heures et que
si on a on a un conseil de sécurité de
l'onu on a des instances internationales
qu il faudrait aussi réfléchir à
l'efficacité des tests de ces instances
qui ne sont pas capables de faire
disputer lé le kef et l'aîné république
il faut faire vite parce que je m'en
sens et quand on voit les images qu'on
entend le garder en ce moment la
situation est vraiment en train de
devenir très critique malheureusement ça
peut très vite se déclencher en guerre
de mouvement et ça ça peut être
catastrophique pour tous les habitants
de la région pour les pays de la région
c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'on ne
l'avait pas revu depuis la guerre de
yougoslavie qu'on n'avait pas vu depuis
la deuxième guerre mondiale l'europe
doit seul à avoir trouvé par et de se
voir si elle le au moins pour raisonner
kiev pour tester le jeu et que les
républiques et qui discutent ensemble
j'espère que lors de ce concert
dominique on va pouvoir arriver à un
consensus sur ce sujet dernière question
rapidement puisqu'ils ne reste plus
beaucoup de temps à nicolas mirkovic
vladimir poutine supervise aujourd'hui
des exercices militaires
manoeuvres conjointes avec avec la
biélorussie des exercices 1 qui doivent
prendre fin d'ailleurs demain le 20
février et puis l'otan va faire aussi
des exercices militaires en mars les
deux parties qui montre les muscles de
ça aussi c'est moi mais si j'ai envie de
dire jusqu'où peuvent-ils a montré les
muscles quand même des différences à la
russie ils avaient eux aussi sont dans
leur pays l'otan est en train de faire
des va faire des exercices pour elle en
fait là régulièrement
donc dans des pays membres mais sur la
frontière de la russie quelle est la
menace que la ressource russie
représente pour les autres pays de
l'otan qu'est-ce que quel pays de l'otan
et ce que la russie menacent donc du
coup faut bien garder ça à l'esprit de
la rue s'il avait l'euro 600 hectares de
leurs frontières les piments de l'otan
font des exercices le long de la
frontière russe sort dans des pays
membres de l'otan également mais le long
de la frontière russe qu'il est
l'intérêt de sa sicile et la provocation
je pense que j'ai peur de cette
provocation très franchement parce qu'au
bout d'un moment ça va dégénérer ça va
dégénérer sur les deux armées on sait
que l'ordre le temps était une
organisation radicalement anti anti
russe
les comptes rendus de réunions les les
communiqués de presse de l'otan sont
constamment contre contre la russie la
russie ne peut pas accepter une
organisation hostile sur sa frontière ça
peut ça peut escalader s'appelait
scanner ce n'est pas dans l'intérêt de
la russian cible se rapprocher l'europe
mais on sait j'ai le temps
malheureusement est habitué du fait et
on sait que les états unis veulent une
guerre sur la frontière russe pour
attribuer la russie pour l'éloigner de
l'europe merci nicolas mirkovic d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes analyse politique président de
l'association ouest est qui oeuvre
notamment dans le bon bah ça de manière
humanitaire puis vous est aussi l'auteur
de l' empire l'amérique empire aux
éditions temporis